There's two more things you need
to know about before you start
optimizing portfolios.
One of them will help your
optimization run faster.
And the other is essential for
you to get the right answer.
We'll start with the faster thing first.
The first thing you can do is
you can tell the optimizer
that it should only look
at certain ranges for X.
In other words, for this problem,
for each of the various allocations,
it's only worth looking at
values between 0 and 1.
In other words, the value of
2 would indicate 200% of your
fund is in a particular asset and
that's not possible.
It's only feasible to have 0% to 100% or
0 to 1 in each of these assets.
So, you can tell the optimizer
only focus on values between 0 and
1 for each of the dimensions of X.
And if you do that,
the optimizer can run much more
quickly because it knows not to look at
other values of X outside those bounds.
It limits the search area significantly.
Another thing you can do with
the optimizers in numbpie are provide
constraints.
Constraints are properties of
the values of X that must be true.
As an example we want the sum of
our allocations to add up to one.
So let's say for example we're for
portfolio of four holdings.
So we have X0, X1, X2, X3.
We want the sum of the absolute
values of those to be equal to 1.0.
In other words, our total
allocation should add up to 100%.
The optimizers we use in this class have
the ability for you to express that and
that guarantees that at the end
when it finds out the values for X,
you end up with a total of 100%
allocated to the various assets.
Now we're going to show you how to do
these two things in the assignment text
itself, because the syntax
is a little bit tricky and
we want to convey to you
exactly how to do that.
So we look forward to seeing
you solve this problem and
good luck on your final project.